hey 42 here if you spent any time in the
cinema recently you may have noticed
that hollywood has a habit of
glamorizing pretty much every profession
it touches for example i'm confident
that very few archaeologists have ever
recovered priceless treasure raiding
tombs you'd have to be incredibly handy
with linkedin to find a harvard
professor with a focus chris crossing
the globe thwarting the efforts of
ancient secret societies and your
average hacker is more likely to be
sitting in their parents basement
searching for cod exploits rather than
taking down the fbi from their swanky
penthouse apartment
another commonly misrepresented job is
that of the assassin
these guys crop up so often in tv film
and computer games you'd be forgiven for
thinking assassinations a booming
industry and a fantastic career choice
there's jason bourne agent 47
deadpool leon the professional john wick
and that's annoying guy from game of
thrones who always refers to himself in
the third person to name just a few but
a quick look at your favorite internet
job board will soon show you that
assassination gigs are actually pretty
thin on the ground at the moment
but for whatever reason humanity remains
morbidly fascinated with the idea of a
deadly assassin emerging from the
shadows to delete some random
unsuspecting vip with extreme prejudice
assassination in one form or another has
been around for as long as there have
been humans
but the modern interpretation of the
master assassin
a skilled stealthy killer who murders
innocent people for religious or
political reasons
can be traced back in time almost 1 000
years
to a historical faction called the order
of assassins
led by a mysterious individual known to
outsiders as the old man of the mountain
the order of assassins became famous for
eliminating some of the most powerful
people on the planet
with apparent ease
they operated in the middle east between
the 11th and 13th centuries
during which time they were responsible
for literally hundreds of high-profile
assassinations
they became so synonymous with the
concept of killing for political reasons
that they're the reason we call it
assassination in the first place but
more on that later in the video
if you're a gamer you may know that the
assassin's creed franchise borrows
heavily from the order of assassins
but the real organization was very
different to the fictional one
the real assassins weren't some kind of
global peacekeeping force seeking to
improve the lot of mankind one
high-profile murder at a time they were
simply a group of like-minded
individuals doing what they needed to do
to survive in a hostile world it just so
happens that what they needed to do to
survive was murder a lot of very
important people
but i'm getting ahead of myself
in the early days the group we now call
the order of assassins that came much
later
weren't killers at all
they were deeply religious members of a
brand new branch of islam that formed in
the late 11th century
after a succession crisis in the fatimid
caliphate a powerful ismaali shia muslim
dynasty that ruled much of north africa
and the middle east around the turn of
the second millennium the seat of the
caliphate's power was in egypt and it
was in cairo that the succession crisis
took place between two of the caliphate
princes
the eldest of the two princes nazar was
passed over for rule in favor of his
younger brother al mustali after a brief
power struggle prince nazar was executed
and his followers were forced to flee
east into persia in modern-day iran
there they founded a new branch of shia
islam called nizari ismailism under the
guidance of a charismatic missionary by
the name of hassan isaba but life wasn't
easy for the followers of this new
doctrine at the time persia was occupied
by the powerful seljuk empire
as sunni muslims the seljuks considered
nazari beliefs to be heretical a view
that was also shared by the country's
sheer minority but hassan was a devoted
and capable missionary and he spent
years traveling persia discreetly
spreading the word of nizari ismailism
and attracting new followers to the
course the trouble was he was almost too
good his activities eventually attracted
the attention of the ruling seljuks and
a warrant was issued for his arrest
hassan was forced into hiding in the
mountains in the north of persia but he
didn't stay there for long he was also
aware that his ability to gain more
followers would be somewhat hampered if
he spent the rest of his life living in
a cave
so he set about searching for a new base
of operations from which he could safely
grow his fledgling religious order
soon enough he found just the place
alamot castle was an imposing mountain
fortress in northern persia
surrounded on all sides by sheer cliffs
and reachable only by a single narrow
track
it was considered to be essentially
impregnable a notion backed up by the
fact it had never been captured by
military means in more than 200 years
since its construction
as far as hassan was concerned it was
perfect a stronghold he could defend
against an attacking army even with just
a few hundred men there was one small
problem though being smack in the middle
of enemy territory alamo castle was
already occupied by the very men hassan
was busy hiding from
taking the castle by force wasn't an
option
despite his successes on the recruitment
front the nazaris had nowhere near
enough men from a frontal assault
that left hassan in what seemed to be an
impossible situation
but as we're going to find out he had a
bit of a habit of making a mockery of
impossible situations
and his solution to this one was
incredibly simple he strolled up to the
castle's seljuk lord and politely
explained that he hassan was now in
charge
and here's the really crazy part
it actually worked
you see before hassan went all peaky
blinders and claimed that alamut castle
was now under new management he
dispatched several of his best men to
infiltrate the nearby villages where
they quietly began to convert as many
people as they could to the nazari cause
over time some of hassan's men were able
to secure jobs within the castle itself
and eventually hassan was able to sneak
inside disguised as a school teacher
slowly but surely more and more people
within the castle walls were convinced
to switch their allegiance to the nazari
this plan took the best part of two
years to pull off but by the time hassan
had made his move and revealed his true
identity
most of the castle soldiers had already
been turned to his cause
the fortress was taken from the
disbelieving seljuk lord without a
single drop of blood being spilt
and hassan not only spared the man's
life he actually sent him on his way
with a good chunk of cash as
compensation for the loss of his castle
not that this generosity helped all that
much the seljuks immediately sent an
army to reclaim the fort
but just as hassan had predicted he and
his men were able to take advantage of
its natural bottlenecks to defend it
easily despite being heavily outnumbered
[Music]
over the following years the nasari
sought out and captured dozens of other
strategic strongholds across northern
persia
creating these weird exclaves inside the
seljuk empire
but the more the nazari grew the more
attention they attracted from not just
the seljuks but also from other nearby
powers the abbasid and fatimid
caliphates the ubid empire and even
christian crusaders who at the time were
making regular forays into the holy land
hassan's nazaris were vastly outnumbered
by pretty much all of them
and the threat of attack was constant
once again hassan was left with a
seemingly impossible challenge
namely how to defend his militarily weak
mini-state from the far larger forces of
his growing list of enemies
the answer as you may have guessed
involved the kinds of tactics the nazari
state which eventually came to be known
as the order of assassins
is famous for today
her son had no hope of threatening the
huge armies of his enemies
but
what he could do
was threaten the men that led them
he began training his bravest most
competent followers in a brand of
warfare the world had never seen before
known as fedai hassan's assassins use
stealth disguise misdirection and
infiltration to directly target enemy
military political and religious leaders
it was pretty ingenious really
to attack de nazari even with an
overwhelming force that was guaranteed
victory was to place a giant target on
one's own back
it was asymmetric warfare at its most
effective
and with it the vastly outnumbered
nazari were able to hold their own
against a whole range of enemies who on
paper were far more powerful
the fedai had many different ways of
eliminating their targets
often the attacks would be carried out
to the public assassinating an important
figure in front of a large audience
ensured maximum political and
psychological impact
the assassins typically use daggers for
the very same reason the bloodier and
more visceral the spectacle the better
for the most important and therefore
well protected targets a fedai might
spend months even years getting close
perhaps even getting a job in the
enemy's household or infiltrating their
guard detail
for less high profile individuals the
fedai would disguise themselves as
beggars or mystics
hiding in plain sight as their unwitting
mark walked right up to them before
striking at the very last second
not all their attacks were made in
public though
according to one story when legendary
kurdish general saladin besieged an
assassin stronghold in 1176
he awoke one night in his tent to see a
shadowy figure disappearing at the exit
at first he thought it was one of his
guards
until he noticed a poisoned dagger that
had been left underneath his pillow
the implication was pretty clear
bugger off or next time we'll stick it
in your heart
needless to say that siege was lifted
the very next day
and the assassins went on to form a
loose alliance with saladin against
christian crusaders in the holy land
along with their skill the assassins
were also known for their incredible
bravery many of their assassinations
especially those of the public up close
and personal variety
were pretty much guaranteed to be
suicide missions
but the fedai
never wavered in fact there are reports
that once their task was carried out
they wouldn't even try to defend
themselves and would simply wait for the
enemy guards to cut them down
according to some that bravery came from
the use of a drug called hashish
taken so that the assassins could
achieve a trance-like focus during a
mission oddly enough that alleged drug
use is actually the reason we now have
the word assassin which is an anglicized
corruption of the arabic word hashashin
meaning hashish user
the assassin's enemies used a word as an
insult
they were basically calling them
crackheads
some historical sources including
venetian explorer marco polo took the
idea of the assassins as drug users one
step further suggesting that opium was
an important part of a brainwashing
initiation ritual used to inspire
absolute obedience amongst new recruits
according to the story wannabe assassins
were dosed up with opium before being
taken to a beautiful walled garden
inside the fortress of alamos this
garden was what you might call mtv cribs
worthy with milk honey and wine flowing
about the place in streams and scantily
clad women singing dancing and well you
can imagine the rest
the recruits would wake the next day
after the night of their lives thinking
they'd experienced a vision of paradise
since the assassins believed this garden
of sex drugs and rock and
milk
was where they'd end up if they died
they were more than willing to lay down
their lives at the drop of a hat
there are even stories of nazari
assassins proving their unwavering
obedience by leaping to their deaths
from high places on the orders of their
superiors
apparently that's where the makers of
assassin creed got the idea for their
signature leap of faith which is found
in the games the thing is it turns out
there's no real evidence that the
assassins used hashish or any other
drugs for brainwashing or for bravery
these stories might be true but they
might also be little more than
propaganda designed to damage the
reputation of the nazari that would make
sense since a lot of what we know about
the assassins comes from contemporary
sources who either viewed them as
enemies or in the case of people like
marco polo as simply mysterious and
strange
the venetian was one of several
westerners who popularized the idea of
hassan esaba as the old man of the
mountain
a moniker that hints at an almost
mythical lens through which many people
viewed the assassins even in their own
time
but whilst it can be difficult to know
where to draw the line between legend
and reality everybody agrees that the
assassins methods were very real and
incredibly effective
hassan forged his followers into an
invisible menace
whose shadow loomed large over the
middle east for almost 200 years
they became so feared that it was common
for their enemies to wear chain mail
under their clothes and surround
themselves with guards day and night
not that it helped all that much when
the assassins set their sights on
someone more often than not they were as
good as dead
in hassan's time alone the order of
assassins are thought to have killed
more than 50 high-profile enemy targets
and under the stewardship of the men who
took on the mantle of the old man of the
mountain after hassan's death
that number is upwards of 200. with many
of those men being world leaders of
their day
the numbers are pretty frightening
but their effect allowed the assassins
and their nazari state
not only to survive but to thrive
spreading out across persia and
eventually syria despite being hugely
outgunned in almost every department by
their many enemies
but all good well
murdery things must come to an end
eventually and for the order of
assassins that end came fairly abruptly
with the arrival of the mongol horde
that rampaged across western asia in the
mid 13th century
in the mongols the nazari state had come
up against an enemy that was simply too
big and too powerful to be intimidated
the nazaris held more than 50 castles at
this point most of them mountain
fortresses
but after some early losses and the
capture of their leader every single one
of them was forced to surrender
alamut castle was amongst the last to do
so in 1256
and
with that the nazari state was all but
finished though nizari political
influence remained in the region for
centuries afterwards
and they never went away entirely the
nazaris are still going strong today
numbering some 15 million followers they
make up the largest branch of his mali
muslims and can be found in more than 25
countries around the world needless to
say things have changed a bit
a lot since the days of the assassins
but the legacy of those more brutal
times lives on they may have ceased to
exist close to a millennium ago but the
order of assassins continues to have a
remarkable impact on popular culture and
many of the methods they pioneered are
still just as relevant today as they
were a thousand years ago
[Music]
thanks for watching